si biche cancérette tige autrement dit
cigarette celle qu'on savoure goulûment
celles qu'on roule patiemment avec du
gris à moins qu'une petite pipe bourrée
soit encore plus délectable mais le
plaisir du fumeur est à quel prix à
partir de lundi à + 15 % une
augmentation du paquet encore une mal
accueilli en général d'un côté on taxe
le tabac parce que c'est mauvais pour la
santé mais d'un autre côté ça rapporte
c'est bien que c'est de l'hypocrisie
plus récente ça augmente depuis ce mois
d'année et puis je crois que ça empêche
pas les gens de fumer je fume un paquet
de nuit par jour et je ne changerai pas
ok pas de l'ancienne usine des tabacs du
Mans alors là on se des cigarettes n'y
changera rien les non-fumeurs non plus
les non-fumeurs on les accepte ils
s'habitent bien à nous aucun problème
c'est pas le contraire
ne nous jamais rien dit je vois pas
oui ils sont mis à fumer